in this movie you're surrounded by naked
women like almost every day it seems
just like it normal to tell you the
truth it was kind of disgusting
sometimes these sequences were you know
they weren't uh very romantic let's put
it that way usually you have to
understand when you make movies there's
a lot of protection in there you know
there's also you know body doubles and
things like that they're all just
another day's work really I mean you
think more about your back hurting than
any arousal whatsoever that's all I'm
gonna say yes the candle scene is that
you or was that a body double there it
was all me do a character like this you
have to go all out you can't we can't
pull any punches and you have to you
have to just uh you know swing for the
fences so when you when you take on a
character like this and you want to
accurately reflect the nature of who
these people are
you just gotta do it you can't you can't
think about yourself because it's not me
you know it's a depiction of somebody
else